it was the pontiff's first visit to  calabria the home of the Indian guetta  Francis gave his blessing to the fight  against Italy's most powerful mafia  group then in a visit to prisoners at  Cassano alo y'know jail he promised that  the church would fight for the rights of  prisoners everywhere he added that  prisons had to do more to reintegrate  inmates into society spittal dddd later  the pope and local clergy held an  outdoor mass his message was that the  church would do everything it could to  combat the Mafia's influence an  estimated 250,000 people heard the  pontiff's words Francis used his address  to declare he was excommunicating  mobsters hey what the ndrangheta is is  the worship of evil and it is the  disavowal of the common good he added  that Calabria has seen firsthand the  effects of the Mafia's influence his  visit there was an attempt to use the  Church's moral power to combat organized  crime